what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
very very interesting news marvel and dc
could have been completely different we
almost lived in a world where marvel
would have been nothing like it is today
the mcu might not have existed but dc
might have actually had an amazing
universe this is all because of one
person kevin feige right now he is
marvel studios as president and is
widely responsible for the creation of
the marvel cinematic universe and all of
the movies that we know and love today
that make up the mcu however we have
learned that this almost didn't happen
because at one point in time kevin feige
was in serious talks with dc to leave
marvel studios and go over to warner
brothers and what's interesting is that
warner brothers to this day still wants
a kevin feige and now especially more
than ever but if kevin feige would have
left marvel back in the day which we're
about to talk about things in each
universe probably would have been
insanely different and dc probably would
have been the better franchise would the
mcu still have existed well probably but
kevin feige really is the mastermind
behind everything so the mcu probably
would have existed but it might have
been caused by kevin feige creating a
dceu a true dceu over at warner brothers
and it might have been marvel trying to
copy what dc was doing because keep in
mind kevin feige has worked for marvel
studios since way before the mcu was
even a thing kevin feige started working
on marvel films in the 90s as an
assistant and then he got hired as a
producer for the first time by marvel in
2000. he worked on those classic
original marvel films like x-men
spider-man the punisher fantastic four
daredevil and the hulk films and then of
course he would go on to create the mcu
however it looks like at one point in
time he was actually kind of
dissatisfied with marvel and almost left
to warner brothers according to a recent
article by puck marvel studios president
kevin feige considered moving to dc
several years back amid frustrations
with the marvel management at the time
and that's pretty scary to hear the mcu
owes a lot to kevin feige without him we
probably wouldn't have any of these
films that we have today and if we did
they probably wouldn't be as good the
stories wouldn't be as good the
directors and probably the casting
choices as well for the actors but
luckily for us marvel fans this didn't
happen any time recently this actually
happened in 2010 now this is after iron
man and the hulk and after the creation
of the mcu so technically the mcu would
have already existed but what if kevin
feige actually left i definitely don't
think the mcu would have been anywhere
near the same but the dc eu wouldn't be
nearly the same as well it would
probably be a lot more successful than
it is now and probably would have been
more successful than marvel studios at
the time now kevin feige seemingly got
what he wanted from marvel studios
because according to this report by puck
the reason that he was so frustrated was
because the old ceo and chairman for
marvel entertainment ike polmader had
apparent opposition to diversity in the
mcu and over the years we definitely
have had a lot of diversity in the
marvel cinematic universe and that is
thanks to kevin feige so it looks like
he got what he wanted now it says that
he was clearly frustrated with marvel at
the time which is why he was talking to
dc but this actually could have been a
really great thing back then because it
most likely led to kevin feige's
promotion this would ultimately lead to
kevin feige being in charge of marvel
studios and i'm talking full control not
just a lot of control but full control
kevin feige having to report to nobody
but everybody working for him which
ultimately led to the success of the mcu
and it looks like warner brothers and dc
are still looking for a kevin feige type
warner brothers has recently merged with
other companies and is now called warner
bros discovery and they have a new ceo
david zaslov and according to the
article by puck he wants to become
disney and i find his plan very
interesting according to this article
they are going to be splitting warner
bros into separate silos they'll have
different sections one is going to be
live action films from warner brothers
and new line cinema another is family
animation and another is dc superhero
projects and according to this article
david zaslov is looking for a kevin
feige figure to come in and help dc now
this could be either a really good or a
really bad thing on the surface you
could say that it's pretty good warner
brothers giving dc kind of their own
department that way it's the people in
that department's job to solely focus on
these superhero projects making the
movies and the shows better and
hopefully working on a extended universe
that actually works and sticks to itself
however if you get somebody to come in
and be in charge of this department they
have to be really really good and they
do kind of have to be kevin feige
caliber which is extremely hard to come
by one doesn't simply just get a kevin
feige to come in and direct their
universe yes lord of the rings pun
intended so again this could be really
good news or it might actually flop like
a lot of the dc stuff has however they
do have a lot of really exciting stuff
coming up in the future and if they do
get the right team i believe that the dc
universe could be a great universe
fortunately for us right now kevin feige
is the president of marvel studios and
it looks like everything that he's
wanted to make happen is happening and
the mcu is extremely successful
especially with the addition of the
marvel disney plus shows and they're
cranking those bad boys out like four to
five a year and that's on top of the
three to four movies they'll be
producing every year as well so right
now it's all good for us marvel fans it
looks like kevin feige isn't going
anywhere but he almost did and the mcu
could have been completely different we
might have all been dc fans and this
channel might have focused a lot more on
dc than it did marvel but for right now
we're good and hopefully dc actually
does get a good person to come in and
get everything rolling for them but in
the meantime let me know what you think
each universe would have been like if
kevin feige would have left marvel and
went to dc let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you